[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now this may sound bizarre but it's the
first time I've actually seen all my
cars in the UK on the track what a view
[Music]
seeing all my babies out for the day
together for the first time
amazing amazing amazing amazing what a
beauty try this one first
[Music]
[Music]
right first time all these beautiful
cars are out for the day together
teller get sweaty so if you piece of
kind of do a favor and get out rockin
way
[Music]
[Music]
this is my McLaren seller only 500 e
beauties were made it's like driving the
fastest roller coaster he's ever been on
[Music]
No
oh my god I want to sleep
[Music]
my Porsche 9 1 is a 4.6 liter v8 engine
with two electric motors this is no
Prius nought to 60 in 2.5 seconds this
Spyder has some bite
just gets better and better and better
oh my god
[Music]
without this is what I call a car every
time I said inside this incredible car
it gives me chills with only 200 and
made on the planet laferrari Alberta is
on a different level nearly a thousand
brake horsepower me it's fast when you
thought the day could get any better it
just keeps on giving and giving and
giving what an amazing day it's a most
amazing cars my new vintage and more
importantly some amazing friends and
family and that's how much this point of
view trust me it doesn't get hotter than
this that is a dream come true
[Music]
you
[Music]